bassem jean castex et est attendu à 15
heures donc devant les sénateurs et ce
matin le premier ministre s'est exprimé
devant les députés
effectivement les gorilles jean castex
est attendu au sénat pour présenter ce
nouveau plan gouvernemental face à la
crise du corona virus mais ce matin
c'était un service après vente assez
agitée qui a dû assurer le premier
ministre devant les parlementaires jean
castex a défendu les nouvelles
restrictions décidées sur l'ensemble des
têtes du territoire suite à l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron c'était hier à 20
heures avant un débat puis elle un vote
un discours d'une trentaine de minutes
dans une ambiance électrique ou jean
castex a tenté de défendre la position
du gouvernement je vous propose
d'écouter jean castex
ces décisions ne sont jamais faciles ne
sent jamais fin elles obéissent à
plusieurs exigences rechercher le
meilleur équilibre possible entre
protection et contraintes agir ni trop
tôt ni trop tard
en s'adaptant en temps réel
aux évolutions de l'épidémie mais aussi
mais aussi aux différences de situations
territoriales notamment en début de
vagues épidémiques bassem un premier
ministre chuté par les élus de
l'opposition très critique envers le
gouvernement
effectivement vers goryl a été largement
critiquée par l'opposition l'opposition
qui a complètement boycotter ce vote il
ya eu 3 148 pour 9 contre des pour bien
sûr c'était la majorité qui s'est montré
très soudés face à ce vote la plupart
d'opposition et n'ont pas pris part au
vote un torrent de critiques notamment
sur les places en réanimation sur la
stratégie vaccinale du gouvernement d
opposition qui ont été critiqués par
jean castex le premier ministre qui a
déclaré que ces personnes cherchent à
tirer des avantages politiques d'un
drame national
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet
messieurs abad et ruffin de la france
insoumise et des républicains pardon ça
fait un an que on vit partant de covile
mais que l'assemblée discute de plein
d'autres choses
qui sont parfois intéressant mais en
tout cas qui discute pas de la stratégie
vaccinale qui discutent pas du
couvre-feu qui discute pas de ce qui se
passe pour le monde de la culture 2 qui
diffuse pas de comment on gère les
écoles tout ça on est out out out et on
s'est mis out nous mêmes je veux dire
que la majorité en marche a choisi de
s'auto démissionner de quel côté va
retomber la pièce la pièce c'est les
français c'est leur enfant c'est les
hôpitaux c'est tout ça et donc il ya
zéro décision qui se prend ici ici c'est
une chambre d'enregistrement des désirs
du président qua non je vais pas prendre
part au vote jeu on va pas aller voter
que tout comme l'est républicain tout
comme les communistes tout comme les
socialistes
donc ça fait quand même du monde qui
pense que ont soutenu quoi c'est un
simulacre de démocratie
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que pour
nous ce débat là alors que les décisions
ont été prises dès hier n'a plus de sens
voilà c'est une mascarade démocratique à
laquelle on ne participe pas c'est
surtout un échec de cette stratégie
sanitaire sur les masques sur les tests
aujourd'hui sur les vaccins le compte
n'y est pas c'est la bérézina sur les
vaccins et c'est pour ça qu'on confine à
nouveau les français
et voilà il ya une attitude extrêmement
forte et donc on a rappelé toutes nos
propositions qui n'ont jamais été prises
en compte avec des mois de retard
parfois et je pense qu'on a eu toujours
un temps de retard et s'était stratégie
du contretemps permanent qui aujourd'hui
met la france en difficulté alors vous
l'aurez compris et grégory va falloir
s'attendre à au même scénario cette
après midi au sénat que celui qu'on a
vécu ce matin à l'assemblée nationale
les sénateurs de l'opposition ont
déclaré qu'ils boycotteront massivement
ce vote cet après midi ici au sénat
merci ben hassen chébili en direct du
palais du luxembourg à paris